this year marks the 10th anniversary of
Pawn Stars on history and it's still one
of the most watched shows on the network
it is crazy popular and of course it
shoots right here in Las Vegas so I got
a chance to go hang with Rick Harrison
and the crew and get a tour of his
one-of-a-kind shop this is a Picasso
Picasso Picasso a real mummy mask how
much for that 40,000
what's the craziest thing anybody's ever
brought in here it was seven human
skulls in a duffel bag apparently there
was a dental school who went to the
auction
that's crazy a bag of skulls yeah things
can get a little weird at the Gold &
Silver Pawn Shop making it a must-see
for fans I am the number one non-gaming
tourist attraction in Las Vegas some
days we get over 5,000 people in there
have you had famous faces walk through
that door
life actually had a lot of famous faces
over the years that partied a little too
much and needed some money for the
weekend they take off the Rolex and I
loaned the money to come back a few days
later pick it up wow this is a San
Antonio Spurs ring from 2003 this is a
player's ring a guy came in and needed
some money to party for the week biggest
check you've ever read um something get
radom you might have to write one today
because we brought some stuff here Hank
air inside Jet magazine come on you
don't see this every day it's worth 20
bucks
nobody got next we have the Spice Girl
dolls in boxes unand this is a
spectacular item 250-258 no altogether
no wonder you're in business yeah I real
well here is this a real dinosaur leg
yep it's 27,000 27,000 for a dinosaur
leg how much would you sell this for
it's priceless I had so much fun and the
place was packed people all wanted to
just get a trick an autograph or
anything they do a little taste up just
a little tape
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]